I've come to meet gym owner fatty that's
about 15 kilos ago yeah so that's
another person so are you competing at
that point I did it at that point I
hadn't competed and that was probably
part of my muscle dysmorphia because
actually in my mind I never thought I
was good enough you think that you were
big enough no no didn't actually didn't
I don't think I was ever good enough I'm
just trying to wrap my head around the
fact that I've seen the photos of you
and I've seen how you looked
Yeah right yeah and so when you look at
them now I mean you look huge right
still gets me till now like geez you
know that was that was me but you didn't
think that you were big then absolutely
not
yeah blows me away that I even took it
that far yeah how far did you take it oh
that's a real question I took I took it
too far and what started with the air
just a little bit of experimentation
ends up being a whole sort of chemistry
mix inside that you're taking yeah and
it grew from there
at the height of it all when you take
the steroids and you were working out of
a lot how was your self-esteem not so
good because I don't think I was you
know good enough and if I was gonna be
judged on how I looked or my body there
not had to be perfect everything had to
be perfect
yeah and you said that's why you didn't
compete by doing a dinner I just put in
all the hard work I'd do everything look
in the mirror and go nuts it's not good
enough
it's not good enough
no matter how big he got fat eat never
felt perfect and three years ago his
physical and mental health got so bad
that he made the decision to quit
steroids how hard was it to get to the
point where you could look in the mirror
and feel happy with how you looked for
me that was very hard that took a while
and that was one of the biggest steps
forward for me it was to be able to look
in the mirror and go yeah look great I
feel good you know you know they have
all these side effects following me
around or negative feelings or any kinda
anxiety like that so that was a big
thing for me that was a massive
accomplishment to be able to look in the
mirror
after that our look in a way Fatih is
lucky by taking his health to the edge
he realized he had a problem to get past
but I've discovered that many people
with muscle dysmorphia don't think they
need help so they don't seek treatment
dysmorphia is a condition in which
someone really believes there's
something seriously wrong with their
appearance when there's not and I wonder
does having a facial recognition of
muscle dysmorphia mean that men's body
image is changing dr. Scott Griffiths
has spent his career trying to make
sense of this it's akin to a reverse
form of anorexia so instead of having
someone who's very very thin look in a
mirror and say to you Oh
grotesquely obese you have guys who are
objectively very muscular and they do
tend to be guys who will look in the
mirror and tell you that they're scrawny
that their puny their weak or that their
grotesquely obese but still that how
their body actually looks is nothing
like how they see it so how common is it
for guys to have this kind of dismal
fear about the way that they look at the
size of their muscles we don't know yet
but it's clear that it's affecting an
increasing number because of what we're
seeing with rising steroid rates that
rise in use is being driven by
predominantly boys and men who aren't
happy with their appearance and want to
use steroids to bulk up so do you have
any idea what's causing this rise in
muscle dysmorphia we have a few ideas
the media environment is definitely
changing research is clear now
that if you look at the trails of men in
the media say magazines on TV video
games they're getting more and more
muscular and lower and body fat they
look less and less like what the average
boy or man looks like this is what I'm
talking about
this is Luke Skywalker from the original
release of the Star Wars film and the
figurine looks almost exactly like Mark
Hamill there's no discernible levels of
muscle mass he's not
weirdly proportioned he looks pretty
similar to the character that he's
portrayed now this is from the 1990s
re-release this character has the
classic bodybuilder physique and pose
yeah
and he does not look like how mark
hamill looked in those films it's huge
isn't it look at those biceps yeah and
it's not the case that you look at this
figurine and then you develop muscle
dysmorphia yeah Star Wars is not
responsible for the existence of this
disorder but in the same way that Barbie
dolls over generations encouraged women
and girls to think that they have to be
massively thin in order to have worth
then boys will think similar they will
come to think that they have to be you
know disproportionately muscular in
order to have worth and that's where
disorders like muscle dysmorphia can
develop guys with muscle dysmorphia
often don't see their bodies the way
other people see them when I dug deeper
into muscle dysmorphia
I discovered that some of the men who
develop it had also been bullied when
they were kids